I was worried the Casimir boys might
risk you all with something dangerously
experimental but I can see it changing
them their bill caponata sir with
sweetbreads has all the hallmarks of a
classic Italian dish but knowing these
boys will be something more to it you
wouldn't do this without a twist there's
gotta be a clue somewhere is it yeah and
I'm something find out where it is
where's the liquid nitrogen what was a
it's a classic dish this has really been
refined so lie again precise temperature
will read into the water bath with the
sweetbreads and the veal they were a
very refined class really consistent and
you got that shitty part with the veal
sweetbreads have Co how you cooking that
we put some in a water bath you have to
arm it 62 for two hours it's gonna be
fun it's a nice class and it should be
just melt in your Maximus diversity
toasty bread made sure when you cook
them they cooked in the center so yeah
some of my coach diners found Peter and
John rates fish and quail too
experimental
I hope that picks the sweetbreads right
for my diners tonight
so is please
jumpin out today
it's delicious
but with everything to play for the boys
are starting to panic in my kitchen
they're out their comfort zone and it's
showing do me a favor don't slice that
veal and she was thirty seconds away
from completing that dish when you slice
the veal what happens to it starts to
get cool that's it yeah what comes out
of it and what it uses so we want no
juicy I'll navigate was that national
flavor you've just bashed your board to
do four stunning dishes a slice at the
very last minute yeah doctor go olive
oil na sangcheo chefs go let's go come
on come on
you can't slice the veal when you five
minutes away from completing the dish
who on that slice when you're seconds
away from that final magic on that plate
we're gonna get rid of nerves now relax
compose step up to the plate quickly I
know you're used to your mum wiping your
ass but I'm not gonna clear down after
you guys yet no [ __ ] way
am i clear down after you in my own
kitchen yes yes sure every time we set
up with this yeah we caraway guys yes
chef that's more we might get in and I'm
short more than yours - you're not
clearing your [ __ ] mess
this sesame addition is sensational
don't worry that's those hot yes a
little bit hot with your water bar be
careful you don't scold yourself sure
I'll get your mum on my back just a mere
clothes table yeah when I last table
going out exactly at the first level
service please go nice and steady
brother good job
so start strong finish quad on down
service is over and we dine as we serve
both restaurants dishes and I'm about to
discover my distinguished guests thought
of them starting with Kazimierz
the sweet blue absolute top yes sweet
red and so what the little big Philip
for me was so far I prefer the Casimir
dish the single element were better and
they mix also was factor for me nice to
see how was it I look at that dish I can
see the boys soul that brought tears to
my eyes
how call me buyers but that's always it
but I definitely prefer the bernoulli
dish the meat was very well cooked and I
liked the combination of meat and
truffle very well done
rocky welcome back so we prefer some
things one obviously what we did was
like it bounced into your marks is what
Registry my diners comments have
confirmed the level of excellence in
this competition now it's up to me to
choose a winner
whatever I decide will affect the future
of both these restaurants and their
chefs